what's going on guys this is rob and i
don't care if anybody watches this video
or not i want to cover ghostbusters
because the trailer for ghostbusters
afterlife at least trailer 2 just
dropped and i am so excited for this
movie so here's the thing those of you
guys who've never followed ghostbusters
it's like one of the greatest movie
franchises in history
except for the more recent one that one
sucked but uh but the other two
ghostbusters one and two were amazing
and this was
a movie series that focused on just
horrifying things right
i mean this was this this thing focused
on disasters
of biblical proportions now you're
probably asking yourself what do you
mean
biblical i mean old testament real world
wrath of god type stuff
fire and brimstone coming down from the
skies rivers and seas boiling
40 years of darkness earthquakes
volcanoes
human sacrifice dogs and cats living
together
mass hysteria but nonetheless like
ghostbusters
was an amazing series i love the
ghostbusters movies so here's the thing
the ghostbusters comic book series takes
place after ghostbusters 2 right but one
of the great things about this is this
has so many callbacks
to the original ghostbusters i mean in
reality this comic is a love letter to
ghostbusters fans right so i absolutely
i adore this whole thing but this
initially opens up with really just kind
of giving us the introduction of who the
ghostbusters are for the most part we
don't necessarily need it but for those
of you guys who are never really
familiar with ghostbusters you've got
peter venkman of course played by bill
murray uh probably the funniest
character
really the only funny character in the
entirety of ghostbusters and then you've
got egon spingler right egon was played
by harold ramis the one of the greatest
actors and movie directors in the
history of hollywood a really dry sense
of humor to be honest uh but he was kind
of the nerdy guy right then you got
winston zedmore who was played by ernie
hudson who was amazing there was there
was this hilarious moment
i think it was ghostbusters i think it
was ghostbusters one
and he was talking to the mayor he's
like since i've been with these guys i
have seen some stuff
that would turn you white
it was it was hilarious and then you've
got ray stance who is played by dan
aykroyd now this is basically kind of
like a big talk show right where the
ghostbusters are basically kind of
conversing and
getting to know the community better
that was kind of a mainstay of the
ghostbusters mythos in like the movies
is that they just kind of
come together to fight ghosts right and
for the most part nobody really took him
seriously and everybody kind of hated
him
until they needed them right until like
the stay puft marshmallow man started
running amuck
in the city of manhattan and then
suddenly everybody wanted the
ghostbusters right so you got these
really cheesy local ads you know like
we're ready to believe
you but it was it was cool right the
whole talk show though is actually
janine's show now janine was basically
the secretary that was brought in for
the ghostbusters to kind of tend to
everything janine was amazing she was a
no-nonsense woman i
loved the character of janine she was
hilarious but it was one of these funny
things where like they're all kind of
talking but they ended up finding out
this was really just a giant dream
because you basically end up having what
was more or less
dana right from the first ghostbusters
movie and the questions asked
like you know race stance are you a god
and he's like uh why yes yes i am and
she's like lie
something like immediately attacks him
right and then he's basically
kind of replays this whole scenario with
the state puff marshmallow man from the
first ghostbusters movie but the funny
thing is that it's actually rey as the
marshmallow man now all this stuff will
make sense as we kind of get further on
into the series because i imagine for a
lot of you guys who never saw
ghostbusters you're kind of like i have
no idea what's going on right now
all i know is there's a giant
marshmallow that's attacking the city
imagine the s'mores you can make out of
that guy but nonetheless this is one of
those things where it's really just a
giant dream that rey has
and then suddenly he's met by the
arrival of john blushie now the funny
thing about this this is a little call
back to something that has nothing to do
with ghostbusters but actually john
belushi was one half of the cast
alongside
dan aykroyd with the blues brothers
which is a classic film if you guys
never saw it you're doing yourself a
huge disservice blues brothers was
amazing so it's just kind of a nice
little little callback to that whole
thing but basically
it's a bit of a premonition that that
john belushi essentially tells rey hey
man
like the the third is coming right like
that's basically what this is right like
there's a third kind of rise demon
entity more or less who's coming
and he's coming for you right now at
that point ray wakes up and it's really
one of these things where the rest of
the ghostbusters kind of starts scanning
his brain right particularly egon
and comes to this realization that the
pke readings of
of rey's brain is really kind of off
kilter now the pke readings are
basically a term used in ghostbusters to
basically measure like paranormal
activity but it's one of these things
where it's just kind of like you know if
a person has
high levels of pke readings then either
they're possessed or they've come into
contact with ghosts the higher the
reading the more likelihood of
possession
and so in essence this dream that ray
had is an actual premonition right like
he really did get a message
from john belushi about things that were
popping off in the future now at that
point
you end up switching over right to this
guy who is basically just kind of
shaving and suddenly met by the arrival
of like a kind of ghost that snatches
him up and yanks him into a mirror now
following that you switch back over to
the ghostbusters that guy who got yanked
in the mirror he'll become important
here in a little bit but you switch back
over to the ghostbusters and you
basically pick up with oscar now here's
the funny thing about this
oscar is the son of dana who was played
by sigourney weaver
uh and appeared in both the ghostbusters
movies but she was really cool in
ghostbusters too
of course she and she didn't really have
the kid with uh with peter bakeman but
her and peter bankman did kind of have a
bit of a thing now the funny thing about
this
in and really even in the comics itself
they almost kind of allude to the fact
that like peter venkman is the father
uh of oscar the reason for that is that
in 2016
ivan reitman who wrote ghostbusters uh
did an interview with rolling stone
magazine and revealed
that it's entirely possible that peter
was the actual biological father of
oscar but it's not really made clear in
the screenplay so they kind of play it
fast and loose the important thing
is that dana and peter never really
worked out because peter was a man he
was sensitive he needed to feel loved he
needed to be desired
i love that quote from ghostbusters too
but nonetheless it never really worked
out the important thing though and and
seemingly what's kind of happening
behind the scenes
is that because of the fact that peter
was instrumental in basically saving
oscar's life from being
basically turned into a vessel for the
carpathian from ghostbusters ii though
there's really been kind of a strong
bond there one of the other funny things
is that sigourney weaver actually did an
interview where she revealed you know at
least as far as she was concerned that
oscar ended up joining the ghostbusters
anyway so a lot of what you're seeing in
this comic really seems to be predicated
on a lot of the kind of
what-if things we wish we had sort of
situations coming out of ghostbusters
one and two and so of course you have
this kind of thing where where oscars is
kind of having a conversation with uh
with winston
and a lot of it seems to be that in a
lot of ways he kind of looks at it as
though his family's cursed because of
everything that went on with janos now
janosh was basically the guy from
ghostbusters 2
that was a servant of the carpathian and
tried to turn oscar into a vessel so the
carpathian could return in human form of
course again
it was all basically stopped but of
course winston's response here is like
look man like there's all kinds of
ghosts around this city
and none of them have anything to do
with anybody's uncle who tried to turn
him into a vessel for
you know a demonic spirit from you know
a long dead empire trying to come back
in human form
so if you do see ghosts it's probably
not because your family's cursed it's
probably because ghosts are dicks so
like they're just kind of chasing you
around and just kind of kind of being
rude about it you know
it's really all it is but nonetheless
they end up kind of responding to some
calls that they get you know different
things like that but in one of these
instances an entire apartment building's
covered in slime and so as they go
through and kind of start investigating
like they literally end up coming
across what is essentially slimer this
slimer is basically one of the one of
the
you know contributions to this whole
thing now the funny thing about that is
that the normal proton packs that they
use
are usually under any normal
circumstance able to essentially ensnare
ghost right that's how this stuff works
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with that the proton packs don't really
exist to destroy ghosts instead they're
basically like giant ghost nets and the
whole point is to drag the ghost down
into the trap where they can basically
be held until they're deposited into the
vault and then basically kept in stasis
right essentially
locked away like a giant ghost prison
the problem is that these proton packs
are not ensnaring the ghost the way
they're supposed to so whatever it is
that's going on here is basically
empowering all these ghosts beyond what
you normally see
and allowing them to escape the proton
packs as they're being used by the
ghostbusters which is a huge problem
because it basically means the
ghostbusters can't do their job
and so following that you switch back
over to that guy who was yanked in the
mirror come to find out his name's jim
silver right and he
is essentially a corporate head for a
company called fz foods which is
basically the parent company of the stay
puft marshmallow man
and because of the fact that the stay
puft marshmallow man was the form
chosen for the return of gozer by race
dance what it meant
is that a giant food product basically
started ripping through the entirety of
new york in ghostbusters one which was
terrible publicity for the company cost
them huge profit losses and all that
kind of stuff and so the results of this
is that jim silver really kind of
responds by threatening lawsuits and so
on and so forth but immediately winston
steps in and says okay look that's not
how this works right like you don't have
a corporate head who just
shows up to a place and says we're gonna
sue you if you don't come with me or
give me what i want he's like usually
they file a giant lawsuit first you
don't even know who's suing you until
you get the paperwork you don't even
know that you are being sued until you
basically end up having paperwork
dropped off on your front door and like
that's it right of course
jim silver is possessed by a demonic
entity hence the reason why he's trying
to get rey why it is he's pursuing rey
will become very very important later on
the important thing here is that once
jim leaves and the ghostbusters end up
responding to a kind of call
and basically leave the island of
manhattan that when you have jim silver
at the top of the empire state building
talking to
you know this kind of ethereal being out
there he's sort of frustrated you know
and really kind of saying look i wasn't
able to get ray the way that you wanted
to but don't worry
everything is going to go off without a
hitch uh they've left the island at the
moment what i need is a distraction i
need something that will bring them back
here and so what he ends up doing using
the power that he has of course as a
result of being possessed he ends up
basically
you know activating or or bringing to
life this bear statue in new york which
is
horrifying right like literally this
bear statue theirs are freaky enough as
it is man bears will chase you for like
three miles i mean bears are nothing to
joke about and so like having one that's
like a giant statue that just comes
running after you it's terrifying
and the whole thing just starts ripping
up the entirety of new york now of
course the ghostbusters are basically
kind of stranded on the bridge with a
busted tire and while they're getting it
all sorted out
egon starts kind of looking around at
everything that was happening with
regards to their proton packs the fact
that they're not working
looking at the pke levels they've been
picking up recently and comes to the
realization that like there is some kind
of force of energy out there that is
amplifying the power of all these
different ghosts that exist in new york
and that they're going to have to
basically increase the abilities of
their proton packs if they're going to
capture these guys more so than that
they got to find the source of this
right they got to figure out what's
going on here with this whole thing and
so what you end up doing
is picking up a few days later when you
end up having them coming across
what is basically spate's catalog now
the funny thing is that space catalog
this is the first time you're actually
seeing it in the ghostbusters mythos it
was referenced in the original
ghostbusters film when dana showed up
talking about zuul and all that kind of
stuff and this being that was trying to
return so on and so this was basically
this this thing where they kind of
reference it as a kind of source
material now
the reality of of spate's catalog is it
was written by a guy named t
watson spates and started in 1901 and
just documenting like spiritual and
paranormal activity
demonic entities different things like
that and in a lot of ways it was just
considered one of those nonsensical
books
write like things about the occult and
stuff like that that nobody ever really
took seriously but given the nature of
their
of their job you kind of have to when
you're the ghostbusters
and so for the most part as they're
going through and looking at this book
there really wasn't a whole lot to
indicate what was going on but then
suddenly
a page grew out of nowhere quite
literally just grew out of the spine
and started talking or really you know
offering information on an entry about
the third and there there wasn't really
a whole lot of information here but it
does lend credence to the idea of what
rey was saying that the third is coming
back we don't really know what that
means
we don't really know how all that
unfolds but of course then you have the
ghostbusters who go after this giant
bear right and for the most part they're
able to to use their proton packs after
they've been enhanced really really kind
of like beefed up and they're able to
basically defeat this thing in the
middle of all of it though suddenly like
jim just shows up like jim silver shows
up and just
snatches ray away right isn't it always
the way rey always ends up being the one
to get snatched up and that's when
peter's like i thought our car couldn't
need people
i thought ecto one didn't meet people
this is weird
but ultimately of course their whole
goal is to find ray now switching over
to rey himself and finding out what's
happening
this is when everything really comes
together and i really love the way that
this is done so for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with how
everything unfolded the idea here is
that gozer is this like
demonic entity that exists out there
right and it's been worshipped by
all kinds of different races over the
years right mesopotamians sumerians
hittites the whole nine yards and the
idea was that gozer was trying to find a
way back to the earthly dimension
to do this you had to have a keymaster
and then you had to have a gatekeeper
and so the way this worked is you had
dana and you had lewis now lewis was
played by rick moranis and the whole
point was that when the two of them came
together they would open the doorway by
which gozer could return
but gozer had to return based on the
concept as it was thought up by a
particular human being in this instance
it was rey and so they all had to clear
their mind so that gozer could not
actually take on a form the problem is
that ray thought of the stay puft
marshmallow man and that's why the
marshmallow man showed up in
ghostbusters 1. and that's what jim
really hits that here when he's talking
to ray he's like understand
you're special right you're not just any
average person out there did you ever
think that there was a reason why the
state puff marshmallow man came back
based on your perception
i mean sure you were all supposed to
clear your minds but nobody did it was
almost impossible for them to clear
their minds
egon was thinking of some abstract
equation ernie was thinking of his time
in the marine corps and peter was
thinking of miss february did you ever
wonder why it is
that your particular manifestation came
back when you look at that and then you
combine it with the events of
ghostbusters too and he goes as far as
to say did you ever think of like the
experience when you were partially
merged with the carpathian
like the whole thing behind this is you
are basically a link to these demonic
entities that exist out there and so
you're always going to end up being the
host right that's the role that you play
now the whole idea behind the third
and this demonic entity that exists here
is that rey is the selector
and this guy is the one who's basically
here to bring about re-selection
the power he has transcends the power of
the gatekeeper and the keymaster the
whole thing behind this is that because
the original ghostbusters basically
failed to bring ghoser back
this guy has now been brought in to
ensure gozer can return
not only can gosu return but that he'll
actually come in as the destructor
and basically lead to all destruction
across the world and that's one of the
funny things
is that gozer showing up can come in a
bunch of different ways
it can come in something as physical as
a 100 foot tall marshmallow that just
starts rampaging through the city or
something abstract like fire or
lightning or floods or something along
those lines but goes is really more of a
concept representing the ends of things
in terms of the different forms that it
can take i mean it is an actual entity
but it can take a bunch of different
forms physical and non-physical
and so that's the whole thing here is
that you end up having rey that really
resists
initially and then is ultimately knocked
out by uh by jim and so because of this
you end up having you know him
experiencing a bit of a premonition
where he basically meets with uh with
john belushi again
and john belushi says okay so here's the
deal man this guy's gonna try to bring
back gozer right like what he told you
is 100 true he's going to try to bring
back gozer
like you're going to have to basically
clear your mind yet again but if you
can't
he's like you're going to have to
basically find a way to ensure that when
gozer returns he takes the exact same
form as he did last time a giant
marshmallow and this makes sense right
the reason why is because if rey thinks
of
anything else right if he thinks of a
storm that's when goser comes back and
is rampaging storms across the world and
it's the end of all things the important
thing here
is that the state puff marshmallow man
was defeated by the ghostbusters before
he can be defeated by the ghostbusters
again with the rest of the ghostbusters
realizing what's going on
and all this energy is emanating from a
particular location they basically end
up traveling there right and when they
arrive
they basically look to try to save rey
and of course the whole point behind
this is them just kind of trying to
ensnare and even offer themselves
as a bit of a distraction by trying to
defeat the third and the reason why i
say a bit of a distraction is because
they don't really have the power to
defeat this guy right this guy's level
of strength is just on a whole different
level right i mean this guy is just
wildly powerful and so ultimately the
purpose is served when the process
begins right and the third tells rey
the selection is beginning choose what
horror goser is going to return as
and he's like this is a puff marshmallow
man
and like and literally the third's like
not again
and so ultimately because of the fact
that his only real purpose is to ensure
the selection takes place
as soon as that selection is done he's
gone right he basically ends up
disappearing and so he's kind of like
i'll return and that's kind of a cool
thing he's like i will always be back
so long as rey lives and even presumably
if rey dies a new selector will be born
and so that person will be chosen
instead
but so long as there is a selector on
earth this guy will always come back
he'll always return in order to force
the selector to begin the process of
selection to decide what form
gozer is going to take when goser tries
to return to the earthly realm now
following that
things end exactly the way that you
would expect right like literally the
state puff marshmallow man gets
obliterated
explodes all over the place and like the
entirety of central park is covered in
marshmallows which
i'll be honest with you guys i'd bolt
out there and i'd be like well let's
make some s'mores y'all
i'd go running out there with some
graham crackers and chocolate and i'd
get to it man i'd be like yeah
we eating good tonight y'all that's what
i would do that's what i would have done
like i would have just
i mean i'm not even lying you would have
seen me just hauling ass towards central
park
with a package of graham crackers and a
bunch of hershey's chocolate but
basically the threat as it exists right
now
is essentially done and of course this
wraps up the first volume of
ghostbusters but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
man
because the ghostbusters comics they're
fun as hell i didn't even know they
existed until i looked them up like
after the trailer came out i was like i
wonder if there's ghostbusters comics
and there are
and they're amazing so like let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section
uh thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace